one of the reasons people are so upset  about joe biden's plan to cancel a lot  of student loan debt is that it just  doesn't seem  fair this unfairness has many levels  like it's primarily a middle-class  benefit that does nothing for people who  couldn't even go to college in the first  place but it's also unfair to people who  did everything they could to minimize  their borrowing or to quickly pay off  any loans that they didn't take out  choosing to go to a less prestigious  institution for going an unpaid  internship working for pay instead of  working on personal projects living in a  cheaper city after college or taking a  more lucrative or less sleep job it's  just something to think about before  acting like the trade-offs involved in  this calculation are all frivolous or  people that are upset by them are all  like mustache twirling villains who want  to see others suffer